[Musica]
a che cosa serve la matematica
venite con me e cercheremo di spiegarlo
per fare questo torniamo indietro nel
tempo di 34 anni
pensate a una giornata milanese di
novembre di quelle odiose una classe
intenta a risolvere degli esercizi di
matematica
ad un certo punto
paolo uno studente
rivolge la stessa domanda
a che cosa serve la matematica alla sua
prof cioè a me
a quel tempo quella domanda mi sembra
quelle cose da un milione di dollari
istintivamente
risposi la matematica serve ad essere
liberi ea diventare persone migliori
vi vedo poco ma sono sicuro che voi
avatar e the avrete la stesso viso dei
miei studenti
allora a diventare persone migliori
certo è perché questo succede non perché
non si capisce perché si assegna sempre
alla matematica
un'utilità di tipo pratico
materiale mentre si lascia alle
discipline
artistiche e umanistiche il resto ma la
matematica
è un ponte è un ponte tra le discipline
scientifiche e tecniche
perché utilizza la logica come metodo di
processo e le materie umanistiche
artistiche
perché
immagina e descrive mondi possibili
ancora volta vi stupirete ma voglio
dirvi che l'elemento fondamentale della
matematica e la creatività la creatività
di rete ecco pensate a un teorema quando
noi immaginiamo o studiamo un teorema ci
focalizziamo sulla dimostrazione
a nessuno viene in mente la domanda da
coda dove è arrivato quello enunciato
bene quello enunciato è arrivato dalla
mente di un matematico o di una
matematica
che ha avuto un'ispirazione
esattamente come un artista davanti a
una tela bianca che immagina nella
propria mente il disegno e poi con
sapienza lo fa diventare un capolavoro
la stessa cosa succede allo scultore
davanti a un blocco in forme di marmo o
in questa bellissima cornice davanti a
un compositore
oa un cuoco che deve fare un capolavoro
ecco la matematica è creatività i
matematici che cosa fanno le matematiche
immaginano una congettura che è frutto
solo della loro mente slegata dalla
realtà e poi cominciano a dimostrarla
magari non ci riescono loro ci
riusciranno
altri o altre dopo ea quel punto quando
sarà dimostrato sarà diventato un
capolavoro perché sarà per tutte e per
tutti è per sempre
a volte con gli studenti dico meglio di
un diamante regalate un teorema quando
volete fare una dichiarazione d'amore
allora è la matematica e di tutte e di
tutti perché non ha confini se ci pensa
tenere lì giorni si ne di genere né
politici né geografici ci unisce la
matematica ci rende liberi dagli
stereotipi dai condizionamenti ci fa
trovare che cosa vogliamo essere non
condizionati dagli altri da dalle
persone che ci vogliono far decidere
quello che vogliono loro per convincervi
di questo vi faccio questo esempio
martina 30 anni single molto
intelligenza e senza peli sulla lingua
laureata in filosofia da studentessa si
interessò ai problemi della
discriminazione e della giustizia
sociale e partecipò la manifestazione
manifestazioni antinucleari
adesso vi faccio questa domanda è più
probabile che martina sia una cassiera
di banca ossia una cassiera di banca
femminista la 87 per cento delle persone
è stato fatto un esperimento in america
rispondono una cassiera di banca a
femminista ma se voi ci pensate
il sottoinsieme delle cassiere di banca
femminista è un sottoinsieme della
cassiere di banca quindi è più probabile
che sia una cassiera di banca ecco
pensate se questa cosa viene fatta sulle
nostre decisioni
noi pensiamo di decidere quello che
vogliamo è invece decidi a decidiamo
quello che ci vogliono far decidere
i matematici e le matematiche non fanno
questo perché sanno distinguere il
probabile dal plausibile perché noi
istintivamente
decidiamo con il criterio della
somiglianza e del ricordo
quell'immagine mi ricorda quel
allora ecco che la matematica ci regala
questa libertà perché ci fa vedere
quando i quali sono i dati accessori e
quali sono invece quelli fondamentali
davanti a un problema o davanti a una
situazione di tipo personale una volta
una mia studentessa mi disse prof.sa che
con la matematica o risolto il problema
con mio padre non riuscivo a comunicare
con lui
a quel punto ho fatto come fa la
matematica mi sono estraniata ho
guardato il problema nell'insieme e ho
cercato
le relazioni tra i dati che avevano e
quali erano i dati fondamentali
a quel punto ho deciso di scrivere una
lettera è magicamente ho trovato il
canale per parlare con mio padre ecco la
matematica ci fa fare proprio questo a
trovare le relazioni tra i dati e delle
informazioni che diventano qualcosa per
noi pensate durante alla pa durante la
pandemia quanti dati quante informazioni
e noi dovevamo costruire dei modelli che
ci permettessero di stare meglio dati
slegati ancora oggi lo vediamo
ecco dove si formano questi modelli
nella nostra mente in questa
cosa fantastica quella creatività
matematica che riesce a creare
ordine dal disordine
e serve ovunque dicevo prima nel
problemi personali a uno stesso
atteggiamento di fronte a una poesia
pensate di fronte una poesia voi la
prima cosa che fate
qual è è comprendere il contenuto il
registro stilistico poi andate a vedere
cosa dice quella poesia in generale e
poi dopo che avete fatto questo andate a
capire che cosa può servire a noi per
comprendere sia all'esterno chi sia noi
stesse ecco la matematica fa la stessa
cosa
così come davanti a una persona che
parla un'altra lingua
usiamo una lingua terza per comunicare e
non importa la lingua terza importa
l'informazione che riusciamo a passarci
ecco la matematica è questo è una lingua
che ci permette di andare in profondità
di non fermarci all'ambiente
alla parte esterna ma di comprendere che
cosa realmente
quella formula dice a noi così come la
poesia quindi in fondo la matematica ci
allena anche all'empatia come fossimo in
palestra non fermarci all'abito ma
comprendere quel chi ci sta davanti e co
pensate ai pitagorici che cercavano di
ridurre i numeri irrazionali a nazionali
quella famosa radice di 2 che non era
trasformabile in una frazione è uno
studente di pitagora ci ha spesso anche
la vita perché diceva non è possibile
trasformarli invece loro no perché era
agosto potremo dire oggi è concentrati e
quindi doveva essere possibile invece si
è scoperto che noi oggi li teniamo così
come sono quindi quando facciamo
2 per radice di tre facciamo dice di se
non li trasformiamo nei decimali
rispettiamo la loro diversità e
rispettando la loro diversità
possiamo fare una marea di cose ecco la
matematica e tutto questo è utilità e
rispetto della diversità e bellezza
intellettuale che ci porta alla verità
alla luce della verità sostenuta dalle
evidenze
ecco alcuni anni fa incontrai paolo vi
ricordate quello studente che mi fece la
domanda che cosa serve la matematica
oggi paolo
parte di uno studio importante
di avvocati internazionale lui mi ha
detto prof
io ho usato quella risposta e la uso
tutti i giorni nel mio lavoro e non
nelle cause proprio importanti diverse
vengo mandato in giro proprio perché c'è
qualcosa di nuovo
e io che cosa faccio cerco di trovare la
soluzione
che come dice la matematica st
nell'oltre è trovata a questa soluzione
la metto a sistema ecco gli oggi vorrei
dare una risposta anche a voi in questo
periodo difficile
di pandemia come uscirne ecco seguendo
la via della matematica
sapendo che c'è un limite ma che limite
lo possiamo superare grazie alla
fantasia e al spirito critico come in ci
insegna la matematica nel rispetto e
nella valorizzazione
delle diversità
sapendo che
ossia che lo possiamo fare che dobbiamo
immaginare una idea nuova e dobbiamo
dimostrarlo
tutti assieme ecco cari amici e care
amiche
a questo serve la matematica
grazie